i know don't worry baby
happy thanksgiving week y'all count down
the turkey day okay i'm here waiting on
my aunties
how you gonna miss three flights in one
day my family
but a little pregame they never heard
nobody
so i got to take this urchin hello
kelly's hosting all her aunties yeah
even the one who
yeah how many of these do you usually
use i think about 12.
for a seven-layer dip do you think you
need that many because i avocad don't
i probably need more my dad inhales the
oh so you and your dad are good
hell no it's just it you know i've
accepted the fact that our relationship
won't be the same
and i'm fine with that well
be thankful your parents don't have new
families me and my mom got to celebrate
with
stanley this year your mama's still with
her
love her project and she's obsessed with
getting to know his kids
like why can't i just overeat and binge
drink with my own blood
wait does that mean you're not coming
over for pie this year oh vic
best believe i'm coming over go back i'm
gonna eat that pie all the way out
i'ma that pie i'ma that pie
you know i've been going back and forth
with this but should i invite andrew
i mean we are exclusive now um i don't
know girl
i mean y'all only been talking what like
two three months
you're gonna pull an old molly and scare
his ass away
you